greenly counselors experiments the
public forests are al Rogalla emergency
vaccinations noted should we be required
to that title building would you please
leave the building bill nearest
available exit from the chamber our 70
points will be public car park at the
scientist Linux please please do not
delay your evacuation to collect any
belongings please do not return to the
building until been commissioned to do
so by council staff meetings are
recorded please note that the recording
of this meeting has now done we do now
please we are standing to the chairman
of the castle the Chairman chapters the
managing director
clearly one sister and I'm not speaking
simply McCreary indeed Europe and good
evening before the press I've been asked
that we remember Vic leach fallen rock
to District Council and also chairman of
Hopewell Parish Council he understand
was a member of both councils for over
30 years he died just at the end of
March and remembered for dedicating his
life for the community
I've been asked if we withhold a woman's
side and let us stand and remember we
thanks Vic Beach
thank you
where'd you be well away the United
Kingdom general election of 2017 is
chedule to take place on the 8th of June
so let's elect the next parliament I
wouldn't dare to suggest who you should
vote for but I'm bold enough to point
you in the direction of the Bible some
guidance in your Testament in the book
of Deuteronomy we find the people of
Israel in the wilderness and Moses is
looking to appoint leaders to guide the
people to the promised land in doing so
he suggests that they should look to
people with the following qualities and
vote for them simply those who are wise
understanding and respective so may each
of us seek to do the same as we vote in
a few weeks time for the wise the
understanding and respected those who
will seek to serve the needs of all
people leading them to a place of
contentment a place from which we can
move on to a place of hope
that is praying
first of all prayer of thanksgiving
Heavenly Father we thank you for all who
are willing to accept the
responsibilities of local and national
governments we thank you for their
diversity of opinions and for the
freedom of the people to choose between
them in the ballot box we thank you for
those who are motivated by a true
concern for the welfare of the
communities within which they serve we
thank you for their unselfish
commitments of time thought and energy
we sent you for the rich tradition of
public service passed from one
generation to another and we prayed for
this meeting
Almighty God from whom comes every good
and perfect gift rather those who hold
office in the Rockford district the
spirit of justice and truth of wisdom
and charity that mindful of their
responsibilities and of the needs of
those they serve they may promote the
true welfare of the people evolve
deliberations and decisions of this
council meeting for the honor and glory
of your holy name we pray amen
trying to say after serving as the T
vector in Raley for the last 12 years
this will be my last meeting as chaplain
for the chairman of Rockford District
Council I'd like to take this
opportunity not only of thanking Carol
this last year but also thanking you all
for allowing me to leave prayers over
what has been the last 10 years with one
or two gaps in between somewhere which I
have to say has been a great privilege
and pleasure to do so so thank you for
your invitation for me and others
to say prayers although I'm now living
just over the border in thunderously or
basically depending on where you'd like
to live as I'm still be taking a very
keen interest in the Rockford district
and I do wish you all well as you
continue to serve the community but
thank you so much and I look forward to
seeing you in my new role as I cover not
only the district of Rochford
but also that have sets have been Hadley
Basildon and Furyk thank you so much
thank you thank you I think Michael just
thank you thank you
Kaleem update tab with July insert
various chairman I'm glad to say and be
something such as what's our own
exclusive thank you for the support
Lewis's staff members themselves the my
hearing of this is a real huge privilege
to be telling what doctor discounsel
I've met many people where champion
volunteers gout playing down nearly
oversleep liquid support and of the next
chairman infected plant Ida and at you
all grown up to your health and reports
they're my animals
thank you very and I think the next
generation let me turn making
recognitions and I have elimination
ticket
Thank You general congratulations on
your year I would like to nominate
council lady with your agenda yes it
certainly there's a light cigarette
second and then nomination
as I remember very much
because you you know
is no solution
I lesbian butcher having been elected to
the office of chairman of the Council of
the District of dropped first declare
that I take that up is upon myself and
will Julie and faithfully fulfill the
duties of it according to the best of my
judgment and ability I undertake to
observe the code out of the conduct
which is expected of members at the
Rockford district council
I would like to say latest he'll be all
year last year done very well and
absolutely with your
healthy and attractive
then come
[Applause]
all right so item number three is to led
to the next vice chair mr. castle
the 2017-18 nuclear regarding the
nomination Thank You jaylen for this
year our Sunday after you serve the
council well over many years that I'd
like to nominate kept very very
happiness my purchases several others
have any other nominations
exactly amendment very good
counselor
[Music]
listen
by David Merrick having been elected to
the office of vice chairman of the
Council of the District of God's Word
declares I take that office upon myself
and rule duly and faithfully fulfill the
duties always according to the best of
my judgment transversal I undertake to
observe the code as to the conduct which
is expected with embers of launch for
District Council
so
[Applause]
how to slice the agenda is for what we
pronounce a quest chapter and I will
confirm that as due to date I can fix
project recipe we have to in the
offering account that Elliott Mason to
cap that wisdom there any others
yes our counselor outs of my little eyes
after seven weeks meeting held inflation
rate for 2007 same mayor correct
I've made enough meat to live chairman
and his great service I'm making the
announcement yet other than to say thank
you very much
nomad
item nine notice a quick membership to
receive big help the notice this
membership that price leader fighters
route and it's not Virata see if that
noted member over then apartment repeat
separate citizen supplemented
Thank You chairman firstly the leader of
the council with evolved into animus
executive portfolios and associated
proteins clicking through ten and there
is a Titan paper that I'll read it
through it by main beam excellent point
mr. 1718 if you project our deputy
leader foods to councillor Michael steps
over that community calls to attend so
Michael went straight supplies counselor
or I know now for environment counselor
add a theory for finance councillors
mean the government's absence row and
planning as reward Thank You channel
click each other
secondly the musical composition of the
council to be reflected in the
allocation seats on the council
committees and subcommittees the
appendix attached report page ten point
five the Tennessee show seat allocations
based on the current conditions in
according to the pro rata rules councils
are asking tulips appendix gem
Thank You general
thirdly grow needless leaders have been
invited to nominate to the council's
committees and subcommittees item 10
addendum 1 commencing on page 10 point 7
set out the members of the creatives and
the subcommittee I think you'd be taking
on board the nomination to see I miss
the council endure such a band of
regenerated Thank You Joan
and finally nominations have been
received and group leaders to the
appointment the Chairman and vice
chairman of committees and subcommittees
and security these are set out an
addendum to all pages 1040 level and
10.12 and can be endorsed subject
accounts leaving the to nominations for
vice chairmanship for the Audit
Committee and two nominations for the
chairmanship of the review committee
turning to my friendship with the Audit
Committee tell them we need to ask for
show hands or cancel FD
thank you
and now the show pans for counselor
Lucas Gill
Jim Klassen leave the scale as appointed
vice chairman of the old activity the
challenges of the review committee first
canon you need to shake hands the
council Burton
and secondly chairman show hands council
coin
general counsel Burton is appointed
chairman of the review committee and
that concludes the support thank you
item seven theme of delegation to brief
stream delegations that happens not
create a theater Constitution with that
great reviews item 12
to approve the chosen team of meetings
of the Council on the 18th July the 17th
of October 2017 the 12th of December
2070 13 February 2018
click the February 2018 and the total
operations 2018 is approved
it was compartments are asked what sort
of those meetings what we NHS people not
absence of a program volume 7 I will be
exploiting region I understand is the
extreme know me
chairman
consideration is certainly be something
currently being given to the best date
for treating University NHS okay how
silver we will utilize
in the next 24-48 hours maximum
item 13 is equivalent objects identity
to that puzzle is not on you Jimmy
Thank You counsel required to make the
decisions set out the page thirteen
point three reports
it's all place to the people through
certain recommendations the first
recommendation is the appointments of an
officer and portfolio over the straps
I've always select community from here
beyond the latest sit down appendix
level of reporters that's on page 13
point 500 reports and ask adults and
children one I do carry it was a.m. get
on the month and information regarding
those four very old relations actually
also and I attended the coastal
communities I don't occasionally
protocol for communities by fire asked
as house I put these at criteria and
appointments monopoly which of wisdom
and one Angela like that all of our
little girls
the projectors down a new capability
certain actions
a
well it is a possibility our green lady
muscle tremors the available called
whole apartment age of five projects
about the rabbit hole people put on the
Saudis are it's not to anything but your
telepath
the general you into recommendation soon
remember representatives including
substitute Lia volunteer for the next
unit circle year to the outside bodies
and experiment all the named bodies and
mama needs this leader the obvious of
setting out on pages thirty eight point
eight and thirteen point nine of
addendum walls for endorsing the wall of
these bodies eruption array Citizens
Advice bureaux shall support to monies
be perceived for one appointment
some German on that basis in regard to
the Citizens Advice bureaux trusty ball
coming as for show of hands for
counselor you are a definitely thank you
Thank You nation
commit is like the show of hands for
counseling mrs. kazar thank you
Thank You chairman so Kelsey you are
over 20 and of all others wins so is
yours
we can really work the next
recommendation thank you
Sharan next recommendation is that the
attendance of the leader of the council
or their nominee and portfolio holders
as the council's representatives and
another of external partnerships be
indoors
Jennifer's counseling Jocelyn enter
general recommendation for is the
cornice of the three seats and the
sanctuary an opportunity for the 2017 18
years for year be named the nominees
were set out at the bottom of page
thirteen point nine of addendum one
attendee general recommendation six is
that the important to the portfolio of
the community to the Essex County wide
travel units and the nomination vehicle
failure hold at the substitute clear
doors
gem quite right recommendation colleague
is at the appointments of the portfolio
to the community to the ethics please
inform travel and the nomination by the
portfolio where the substitutes be
endorsed with handle assembly in
praising Germany recommendations it's
that the importance that the portfolio
health of the community to the ethics
countywide travel units and the
nomination violence of Mario hammer a
substitute be endorsed counselor docks
at gem with great radiate and final
recommendations and recommendation seven
appointments to the four seats on the
local pilots panel chairman the nominees
to set out on page 13 content again is
one there are five nominees for four
appointments
such an we can ask for hands age in turn
starting with shorthand for council
Hazelwood please
could we now have a show of hands to
cancel applauding please
Jenica we have a show of hands a council
vote please
can we have a show of hands the council
wallet please
Sherman can we have a show pencil mrs.
Mason things
German appointees our council table you
are lit this drug and council war that
includes the supporting
[Music]
amazingly on clothes at
the upstanding the gym and director